hello reject nation Greg Alba here John
old we are going to continue Cobra Kai
here we got four episodes left we space
these out because we're not the biggest
fans of binge watching ourselves and not
too many people actually watch these so
we do them for the few for the real fans
male fans and on top of that to those
same people who watch it also complain
every time how we got these out late
it's kind of funny how you keep watching
and complaining at the same time I love
that because the way YouTube's rules
work with TV shows most of our TV show
reactions have actually been blocked
from other shows we've done before we
can only show ten minutes here but on
patreon that's where we do full-length
TV show reaction watch alongs and over
there I cover attack on Titan who did
most of the flash season four I started
up Gotham recently John covers Riverdale
Atlanta Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood
he just started up channel zero together
we cover my hero academia of course
Cobra Kai almost done with Jessica Jones
season two one more episode of black
lighting left we will do those soon just
want to shout our patreon out because we
got so many contributors over there
right now thank you guys so much we also
do weekly QA days and music video
coverage thank you guys for being so
awesome and helping support the channel
any hope let's get on with our Cobra Kai
[Music]
huh
wax on Oh know what that was maybe a
little reference third bow that's right
[Music]
you can't do anything right Danny
no it's just that all cleaning and
maintenance is a good metaphor for more
for there's a wax on wax off really
cares I'm all done well you [ __ ]
both watts
she's [ __ ] I thought you were gonna
teach me karate I'm just doing all your
shitty chores
it is karate and you get paid yeah
thanks the best that really works
Wow I'm shot
watch how that hair back no wow I got I
got clean guards yeah you go back to the
lot right quick no kiss Hey Oh each and
every one of you is gonna take a punch
very hard to face what AM news yes do
you need to have any credentials before
you open up a karate school first aids
under the counter we got a bleeder
there's a girl at school you always do
oh then we'd have a bigger problem
we got a [ __ ] on our hands
I mean Robbie knows how to wax on wax
off now that true get a couple more
shifts over your mark i've been
masturbating to you lately I mean I
would like to don't take no for an
answer never accept there he is
puncher what if it's not a date what if
it's just two people kept saying please
look at our data mine separately but
what if it's just a boy standing really
it wouldn't be name yeah hell yeah
[Music]
uber thank you okay Oh progressive it's
the future they're just hanging out it's
okay yeah exactly they were both gonna
pay for dinner instead of a bee
damn it Robbie do you want the
observatory it's very basic one very
specific Griffith Observatory no you
don't ban me oh we don't take no for an
answer you said that you gotta fight
this know what I'm saying
maybe there's a more delicate approach
sensitive the way the fist is not
delicate
Davee text fast yeah now he wrote all
those out in advance and it was paced
yeah so if you get pissed off what are
you gonna do
I usually just punch the guy someone
makes you angry you you make a fist like
you're gonna punch them but don't punch
the briefcase what's inside
nothing down in the dumpster whoa this
is a real place this is near us
definitely a real place no it's nicer
than the Sherman Oaks Castle partner and
see you know that this show is based off
oh that's a cute date I'm John Lawrence
here for the tournament committee
meeting my dojo has been banned from the
under-18 tournament I know we could ban
anyone in said I just bear with us sirs
probably just a mistake what's the name
of your dojo Cobra Kai
damn wants to re-enter oh I'm sure he
does
Oh Civil War yeah yeah reflux you only
put a wok them
nice Wow
yeah he got really good really bad yeah
hey Danny Larusso oh my god I'm rooting
for him
I know right I really turned this around
[Music]
you better watch you of this
why is he from New York he's a hooligan
that's why all the photo foods kisses
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
problems in the eighties my sense they
didn't always play by the rules that's
why I left but my Cobra Kai is different
it's a place where kids can come and
feel like they belong where they won't
get picked on just cuz they're a bunch
of losers because they're unique Cobra
Kai is making a difference in these kids
lives and honestly they're making a
difference in the mine as well
oh damn emotions that doesn't sound at
all like the old Cobra Kai badass name
for dojo by the way this is horseshit
this guy biggest bully in my high school
he hasn't changed at all
again it's like a general fighting
position but she already knows oh damn
[Music]
Danny Larusso do that move that she did
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're all having beer
yeah yeah it's cute hooray for Cobra Kai
look guys if anyone gets upset that we
take so long to do the next episode
trust me it's us yeah I'll watch the
next one I love this [ __ ] I did I
genuinely love this [ __ ] I look forward
to these shoots every week yeah this is
amazing I thought everything in this
episode was I have no criticisms I've
zero criticisms towards this episode
right now you can't clear this I don't
know if it's my favorite episode but
it's definitely up there every episode I
usually have a little bit of something
to say this so I'm like everything is
perfect to be and the way this is all
executed man every plotline every detail
they chose that focus on everything was
pretty rewarding no characters were
annoying or anything like all that stuff
with Robbie learning the karate from
Danny and then applying it to go against
those people who were a bad influence on
him I thought was really rewarding -
Robbie's a character it's really growing
on me I don't you guys want hero
academia but he's kind of debacle ego
character realize he wants to be better
yeah exactly
I've really been enjoying his arc here
and I think it's really interesting
seeing the switcheroo that they've done
with the show cause Cobra Kai in the 80s
the movies they've attracted people who
were like bullies someone who would be
more like a Robbie someone who wants to
learn how to kick ass more efficiently
than they already actor
I was harm and stuff and then there was
mr. Miyagi who would attract someone
like Danny Larusso who was the kid that
would get bullied and now the kids who
would get bullied or a Cobra Kai and the
kid who would do the bullying is with
Danny Larusso yeah and you're watching
these kids get it grow and learn the
good qualities from these teachers
you're also seeing the impact that it's
having on the instructors as well yeah
because they both have some growing up
to do and like the show doesn't shy away
from that you know it lets both Danny
and Johnny be real people and there are
times when you're like both of them calm
down yeah and I appreciate that and to
like I like they gave Robbie not only a
chance to come around as more
a likable character but also like he's
kind of clever in this episode a couple
times both like you pointed out with the
recording the code has front face camera
and then I should the way he traps them
at the end right under the security
camera like he knows he probably can't
level the both of them but if he can get
a glimpse of them on the camera you know
yeah my only criticism I have of this
episode is the two bullies the two guys
who are like playing in influence over
there I've lived in LA my whole life I'm
like I've never met anyone who seems
this artificially bad yeah yeah yeah the
one guy seems like some creepy guy from
the East Coast the black guy seems like
an actor seems like he's auditioning and
then moonlighting as a criminal I don't
really buy it but that's the one I
thought was good I'm at the point now
where no matter what happens I've
officially switched over to Cobra Kai I
decide because when they had that
victory at the end both Miguel and
Johnny I felt so happy for both of them
especially Miguel like this story line
between Miguel and Sam I really have
been enjoying this really heartwarming
and touching and does bring me back to
that youthful side oh and especially
when they go out to the arcade oh yeah I
wonder how the they shot that even cuz
some of the stuff is just so natural you
know like their their chemistry and just
the fun that they're having really comes
out there back and forth is great and
when they kiss a little bit teary I have
a joy I feel it I was really happy for
it the kind of moment many of us longed
for in our youth and I like that Miguel
plays an influence on Johnny as well in
terms of how to be a better person
Johnny straight-up took his advice on
how to get Cobra Kai into the
championship tournament
yeah and that was a rewarding scene to
to actually watch the emotion creep into
Johnny oh yeah I realized that he has to
yeah just to this and to be bigger than
Danny's being at the time because
Danny's being pretty petty at the
meeting like he's being pretty shitty
about that yeah that's just an instant
way to lose yeah like a cool dynamic
about this shows like whenever Johnny
and Danny are in the same room
Danny kind of becomes the bully by proxy
especially what other people are around
yeah it really wants to prove to
everyone like
no this guy's sorry well you know why
when they're alone you see the dick come
out of Johnny he's yeah yeah yeah
they're still both very much at odds and
that's what makes things interesting
that's what makes not like suspense is
the exact right word but it does give a
certain amount of suspense for how this
is all gonna end up because they both
psych each other out so what they
actually get to the tournament like I
wonder what's gonna happen there - yeah
it was cool to kind of see the art
that's already happened with Johnny
being affected by the students when he's
giving that speech of how much the
students have impacted his life I
thought that was great because my first
he was negative towards the kind of
students that were coming and now he's
feeling really positive towards it just
him and Miguel bonding at the end it was
like yeah good for you guys I wanted to
have a shot with them don't hate Danny
at all I have nothing against the way
the shows going I'm like yeah I'm hoping
in the yang Cobra Kai comes out on top
in this situation yeah yeah well and I
wonder how their conflict is going to
resolve or not by season's end and I
feel like they might surprise us with
something or else they're gonna learn to
respect each other and we'll have to
find a new conflict season yeah exactly
but it's kind of cool to see how it
started off for just two storylines
Johnny and Danny and then there's like
story lives are trickled down from their
storylines and now we got this whole
ensemble of a show now you got Miguel
and you got Robbie yeah that's Sam and
even the additional side character
students who are at the Cobra Kai dojo I
love this show this show is amazing and
we got a lot of tattoos
we should yes there's the next on the
box could get like $800 for that piece
this is what I want I don't know the
artwork wasn't actors
I know tattoos I have several yeah your
these are covered up sleeves right this
is all a skinned tattoo really on pale
yeah yeah you decided that you were done
with tanning so you're just like ah take
me a few shades I don't want to spend
money every month for this anyway guys
well thank you for watching full length
reactions are over at our patreon for
all those shows that we mentioned as
well you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation please click that
notification bell and we'll catch you on
the flippity flippity flippity
it